you can suffocate able starve it lock it
behind bars but it will find a way to
come back even stronger
there was only one true way to end evil
to finish it for good
let the devil out
hey everybody its charlie we got brand
new daredevil footage to break down in
an official premiere date October 19th
way earlier than I expected I'm so happy
so we'll talk about all this so there's
a bunch of bible metaphors that they're
using to talk about the relationship
between the kingpin and daredevil during
season 3 there's a new round of that
spider-man ps4 giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video fun fact -
spider-man has worn the daredevil
costume remember it's all New York City
so in the comics daredevil has worked
with a lot of Avengers level heroes but
they haven't really done that in the
movies or the TV shows yet for those of
you that have always wondered why they
haven't features the Avengers Tower more
prominently in the Marvel Netflix series
they try to talk around that but it's in
the background of this daredevil season
3 poster you can see it very faintly it
just at the sky is solid red so it's
kind of hard to pick out shapes but just
to remind her about the timeline of
these series every single Netflix series
that's dropped this year all the way
from Jessica Jones season to Luke Cage
season 2 iron fist season 2 in now
daredevil season 3 all happening before
the snap we don't know exactly how long
before the snap is just post Civil War
pre infinity war or at least the end of
infinity war before they come to the
sanctum because unless you're Stan Lee
driving the bus there and you see aliens
every other day of the week you would be
freaking out if there was an alien
invasion but the whole thing here is
that we actually got some confirmation
about what Matt's status is in what
daredevil status is during the season
I've talked about daredevil why he goes
back to the black costume because of the
fake daredevil that kingpin creates to
discredit the real daredevil so that he
can't continue using his costume in his
name that the police are out for him you
see Matt fighting all those FBI agents
in the black costume so clearly the FBI
is on the hunt for the devil of Hell's
Kitchen you see him all bloodied up in
his lawyers uniform so obviously that
means he will be part Matt Murdock for
at least some of the season you see him
walking through that prison well they're
talking about defeating the devil
obviously implying the kingpin will get
out because you see him putting on the
classic comic book white suit pulling
that ring drawer
open and then there's a Bible verse that
they used to tweet this out it was
Deuteronomy 30:15 so I'll talk about
that in a second remember every time we
talk about daredevil there's always
gonna be some religious iconography or
metaphors like you see him training you
see him all bloodied up in different
scenes inside what seems like the
convent that he was in at the end of
defenders remember his biological mother
Maggie is a nun at this convent where he
winds up so it sounds like he might be
spending a lot of time with her the same
way he did with father Atlanta during
the first two seasons but because foggy
and Karen were in that church at the end
of defenders in father Atlantians church
I'm assuming that he'll also be around
too but whichever church he's in it
seems like this is gonna be his base of
operations for at least the second half
of the season because I think you know
he wakes up he search to find out what's
going on then he tries to go about
stopping the kingpin from getting out of
prison using legal loopholes and
obviously there's a lot of talk of false
prophets and Bible metaphors that it
gets back to the Deuteronomy quote that
Netflix teased out it's all about the
people of Israel taking the wrong path
following the true Word of God so it
just sounds like the people of the city
will wrongly take kingpin side in the
kingpin versus devil of Hell's Kitchen
Matt Murdock fight that's probably why
he says he stops believing in justice in
that last teaser that I did a video for
like maybe these scenes with him and his
lawyers outfit when he's walking around
the prison happened earlier in the
season then things go sideways the law
turns against him when it shouldn't so
he has to quote/unquote set the devil
free become the devil like when his face
in the costume goes all serious to
smiling like he's really happy to let
the devil out and it's gonna be a lot of
fun that's what all the actors have been
teasing out since they dropped this
footage this morning let the devil out
even Deborah Ann Woll who plays Karen
Paige tweeted out let the devil out so
this is sort of like their marketing
phrase that they're using to sell this
series implying let the kingpin out but
also let the devil of Hell's Kitchen out
the devil inside Matt so if you've been
craving a really dark really
action-oriented fight between the best
Marvel Netflix villain one of the best
villains from anywhere in the Marvel
Universe in Matt Murdock definitely my
favorite Netflix defender character but
also just a really awesome Marvel Kerr
in general - they're releasing an
official trailer in New York comic-con
that'll be like - two and a half minutes
long it'll be more straight up less
metaphors about the Bible more just
straight up action from the series with
the characters actually interacting with
each other but the one thing they
haven't done yet is started leaning on
the boxing metaphors because now it is
time for a rematch like the kingpin is
putting his boxing uniform on that white
suit from the comics you could say that
every outfit that Matt wears is a boxing
outfit like he boxes metaphorically in
the courtroom but also literally at
night when he's acting as a vigilante
the actual deuteronomy quote it's
Deuteronomy 30:15 and it says see I set
before you today life and prosperity
death and destruction and if you're not
a Bible scholar which most people aren't
it's Moses speaking to the people of
Israel sort of transferring power to
Joshua because the book of Joshua came
after this so is all right before they
get ready to head to the Promised Land
so like really awesome things on the
horizon
Moses is telling everyone please don't
be led astray it's all about the kingpin
usurping the promised land because
remember the kingpin even if you haven't
played spider-man ps4 or seen any of the
cartoons or other movies that have
involved the character he's called the
kingpin of crime-- for a reason not not
only is he a really badass sumo fighter
he is really hard to beat in a
one-on-one fight kingpin is resilient
enough to even last a little while
against one of the iron fists Luke Cage
might be able to take him down but it
would take some doing it'd be like a
giant cement truck trying to fight
another giant cement truck we don't see
any official pictures of bullseye in
this remember he's supposed to be an FBI
agent so I'm assuming that it's his FBI
team that Matt's fighting in this
warehouse fight here but the good news
is is that they're bringing that actor
along with the main cast to New York
Comic Con so they'll drop the trailer
they'll do a big panel explaining what's
going on with their characters and then
there's a whole bunch of other New York
Comic Con TV and movie comic-book stuff
so I'll just announce more scheduled
videos and remind people about what's
going to be happening as we get a little
bit closer it's still a couple weeks
away but we're gonna see more daredevil
teasers like this here's the thing
though the reason why I think that
they're dropping this so soon is is
because October is a really big time for
people watching TV so they want to get
that big audience but
also because they were banking on Iron
Fist season 2 not being super popular so
they're like okay we understand that you
really want daredevil season 3 so we're
not gonna make you wait super long after
iron fist to watch that because normally
we would only get like three Netflix
series per year but now it seems like
we're getting up to four so they're just
shrinking the amount of time between
each of these series dropping so you
just have to wait less before we get the
next big thing
so Punisher season 2 is probably gonna
be the next big series after this in the
spring what's gonna happen is is there's
a New Avengers video new venom that I'm
working on they also drop some more
footage for some of the other TV shows
so I'll try to get to those videos as
fast as possible I'll just remind people
about the schedule on Twitter click here
for more new Captain Marvel footage and
click here to learn about avatar the
last airbender getting a brand new
series on Netflix time to freak out
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight